autrefois jadis naguère les conserves
c'est l affaire des grands mères mais
les choses depuis ont bien changé
aujourd'hui on trouve plus branchés pour
nous conseiller
c'est quelque chose que j'entends
beaucoup à ma grand mère fait ça comme
ça il ya 50 ans puis à personne damman
chez nous
sabrina thériault est une passionnée en
la matière elle donne des formations et
l'autriche du livre mais ce concert pour
faire vos concerts de façon sécuritaire
deux méthodes qui utilise la chaleur la
stérilisation à l'eau bouillante et la
stérilisation un autoclave il ya deux
types de conserve en fait il ya des
acides et non acide donc la ph la ligne
de délimitation est au ph 4 points 2 ce
qui est andrew 4.2 ph c acide ce qui est
au dessus 4 points de ph et non à 16
les conservacy dont on les traite dans
un bain d'eau bouillante dans une
casserole d'eau bouillante et salée qui
sont non à ceux dont les traite à
l'autoclave
vous trouverez sur le site du mapaq le
ph de la majorité des aliments les
aliments acides comme les pommes
framboises fraises et bleuets sont
naturellement protégée contre la
croissance du clostridium botulinum une
toxine qui affecte le système nerveux un
traitement à l'eau bouillante suffit
pour en éviter le développement dans le
cas de la tomate dont le ph est limite
il faut ajouter 1 acidifiant comme le
jus de citron pour garantir des
résultats sécuritaire les aliments peu
acide doivent être stérilisés à 116
degrés celsius pour détruire la fameuse
bactérie et seul l'autoclave peut faire
c'est le cas de beaucoup de légumes
viandes ragoût sauce à spaghetti et
bouillon un autoclave c'est un gros chat
drom qui est hermétique dans lequel on
met un petit peu d'eau on remplit pas ce
bo1 on allume la lumière et d'enfants
l'ombre et porter à ébullition quand
l'eau bout ensuite elle s'évapore mais
comme le chaudron est hermétique étanche
la vapeur à l'onu temps pour s'en aller
avec la vapeur va se mettre à circuler
ce soit qui va faire augmenter la
pression de la pression faire augmenter
aussi la chaleur de cette façon on
atteint la température sécuritaire 216
degrés celsius et attention un
autocuiseur n'est pas un autoclave
l'autocuiseur sert à accélérer la
cuisson de la nourriture donc on a de la
pression mais on ne sait pas vraiment
combien puis c'est pas important de
savoir antique avec l'auto club
l'objectif c'est de détruire des
bactéries donc j'ai besoin de savoir à
quelle pression je suis pour être
capable d'atteindre le bon degré pour
des capable de détruire les bactéries
pour faire la démonstration d'autoclave
peut utiliser de la viande que on a fait
colorés comme à l époque 8 jusqu'au
centre mais on voulait donner un petit
coup de chaud caramélisation pour la
savoir non monsieur à l'époque moi je
on va ajouter du bouillon de boeuf dans
cinq ou six puis on va se réaliser à
l'autoclave
verrouiller le couvercle en place et
laisser la vapeur s'échappe et
régulièrement pendant dix minutes avant
d'y mettre la pesée régulatrice
aux maîtres indignes oui en fait c'est
toujours en fonction de l'altitude donc
en bob à 2 300 mètres d'altitude par
rapport au niveau de la mer du space
italie quand on est à montréal
aujourd'hui on va mettre des sps mais
avant d'autant que le vent se lève
et qu'aujourd'hui on a de la viande dans
le bouillon des pour 500 millions
travaillent 75 minutes de temps
stérilisation donc il faut que la pesée
dandine pendant 75 minutes sans arrêt il
est important de respecter les durées
recommandées à chaque étape sans
compromis on garde la pression stable
toulon de la starisation on éteint la
cuisinière moi je recommande de faire
engueuler fois la hâte un joueur d'euro
jacques la charge de moitié à 35 minutes
et time complètement ensuite on touche à
rien laisser la pression tombe
d'elle-même à zéro à la fin du processus
le contenu pourra être conservée
température pièces
pour la stérilisation à l'eau bouillante
des animaux acide on utilise une grande
casserole l'important est que le
chaudron puisse contenir assez d'eau
pour submerger complètement l'epo moi
j'aurai 40 toujours d'apporter de la
nourriture bouillante dans les pôles si
on veut mettre les chances d'un côté
c'est plus facile de traiter de la
nourriture qui fraîchement sorti du
chaudron bouillant
avant de procéder la ville et pau vous
pouvez réutiliser les peaux et les bacs
des années précédents mais il est
préférable d'utiliser le disque neuf
pour que le caoutchouc puisse être
scellé correctement on en potes on
respecte toujours l'espace de taille de
l'espace de tête c'est l'espace encan où
est-ce que pokam ans où est la
nourriture commence fait qu'une fois les
gens pensent que ça commence ici
l'espace attaque avec une 1/2 po c'est
parce demi-pouce le qu'on veut c'est ici
qu'on veut c'est de moitié aux mortiers
vinaigre à 5 % d'acide acétique une
pincée de sucre 1 pincée de sel c'est où
l'espèce docteur un demi pouce pour
l'irlande pas plus pas moins un demi
pouce également pour les fruits entiers
ou tranché ainsi que les salsas chutney
etc et chats en quart de pouce pour les
confitures gelées et marinades et
finalement un pouce pour les aliments
peu acide à l'autoclave on peut prendre
un couteau à beurre ou un manche 2
cuillères à soupe ont fait ressortir les
bulles d'air parce que quand les bulles
d'air remontent à la surface mais
surprise ça fait baisser l'espace de
tête fax quand les bulles remonte on a
juste l'espace de tête
sabrina et suit soigneusement le
pourtour des baux à l'aide d'un linge
imbibé de vinaigre avant de refermer
sans procès et bach la technique et
demain je peux être important de son
bureau m ensuite de haine
jusqu'à b6 on sert trop lherm pour à
s'évacuer de la conserve et on
n'obtiendra pas le vide désiré reste
plus qu'à plonger les pots dans la mare
be ok de l'eau où tu découvert dès que
caen va mettre l'épaule ébullition de
l'eau voire et est ce normal quand
l'ébullition reprend c'est là qu'on va
calculer le destine aux 15 minutes peu
importe puis quand c'est terminé on sort
les pouces et où on laisse reposer de 12
à 24 heures le disque devrait se courber
vers l'intérieur signe que la
stérilisation a fonctionné
travail se plaisent en respectant les
techniques
plein hiver ben ça sent l'été au 5 août
la bonne
[Musique]